now nearly crowned formerly world
champion Jake Dennis says he's open to
competing to Formula One in the future
the Avalanche Andretti driver became the
first ever British Formula E world
champion this past weekend in London
which was staging the season finale
Dennis has been a test driver for F1
team Red Bull has been speaking to Al
Jazeera Sahel Malik about his Triumph
and his future
and it's obviously a really incredible
achievement of obviously what we've left
London with
um there's uh yeah the emotions I felt
on Sunday uh and Saturday really uh was
was pretty special to obviously share it
with my team all the hard work
everything what went into the whole
season uh was just something I'll never
forget you know it still gives me
goosebumps now thinking about it magic
you join a list of elite British world
champion drivers likes the Lewis
Hamilton Colin McRae Nigel Mansell who
are the drivers that have inspired you
on your road to becoming a world
champion
when I was younger I actually never
really had too many inspirational people
to like look up to I always try to like
be my own person uh so I actually didn't
really ever Inspire to be you know the
next Lewis Hamilton or
um yeah Nigel Mance or anything like
this but I think as I got older I
started to learn a little bit more about
I think James Hunt I think he was a a
really cool racing driver you know he
would took he enjoyed life he didn't
take racing too seriously I would say if
I had to choose anyone it would be more
along his lines but nevertheless
um yeah I always tried to choose my own
journey and not really
yeah tried to copy anyone else now when
dretty Auto support have been pushing to
be part of Formula One if that happens
is joining their Formula One team
something that would appeal to you I
mean it's definitely an interesting
topic uh for sure I think you know I
think if the opportunity came about it
would be definitely something to
consider uh you know but nevertheless I
don't think it's always
the best thing to do to go into Formula
One you know you've seen that the lights
are of Nick the frizz who didn't have
the best of cars and then
it's then very easy to be forgotten
about and you know you're only as good
as your last race in Motorsports but you
know I am obviously uh very interested
in Formula One it's something which I've
always been involved in something which
from such a young age I think everyone's
involved in and
um it would appeal to me but
yeah I wouldn't make any Rush decision
to jump directly into it